bonsoir tout ce qui s'est passé depuis
hier depuis l'intervention télévisée du
ministre rené monory ouvrant un droit de
réplique ce soir vous l'avez vue
ressemble à une accélération dramatique
de la tension entre les étudiants et le
gouvernement
voici les faits c'était cette nuit dans
le quartier latin jeune homme de 22 ans
est violemment frappé par des policiers
membres de la brigade mobile
il décède d'un arrêt cardiaque le
procureur de la république dirait
aujourd'hui que sa mort est due à une
décompensation cardiaque
créé par un état pathologique rénale
antérieur le jeune malik oussékine et
est dialysé
cependant plusieurs témoignages
concordants ont rapporté depuis cette
nuit le matraquage auquel il a été
soumis avec françois corner et patrick
voix et le service d'information
générale de la rédaction antenne 2 voici
ce que nous avons pu reconstituer de
faits avérés
le massage cardiaque restera sans effet
eu malik oussékine va mourir
effectivement d'une compensation
cardiaque selon les premiers éléments de
l'autopsié la victime a pourtant reçu
des coups c'est visible et de nombreux
témoins de la firme mais aucun des
hématomes subi selon le parquet ne
semble expliquer seule la mère du jeune
homme ait aucune fracture toujours selon
le parquet n'a pu être décelée à la
radiographie un point semble pourtant
clair il a bien été matraqué rue
monsieur le prince alors qu'il tentait
de se réfugier dans un immeuble
poursuivis par les forces de l'ordre
un témoin capital paul baysse nous
fonctionnaire au ministère des finances
entendu cet après-midi par ses
enquêteurs doligé est-ce que nous allons
boire la police de polices est formel
rentrant celui il a essayé de faire un
prêt malik oussékine dans l'immeuble
la jeune homme a voulu rentrer donc cher
t'es pas ça fait ses revenus donc j'ai
ouvert la porte pour laisser entrer et
j'ai fermé la porte aux crs mais cela a
malheureusement avaient mis leurs
matraques entre les deux battants des
portes dont six mois ferme la porte
ils ont pensé parce que j'ai résisté
compte environ et
ils étaient trois ils étaient beaucoup
plus forts que moi discussion possible
ce qui s'est passé à ce moment là et se
sont précipités sur je crois que sap
lémanique
qu'on m'a trahie et copines
et
moi j'ai reçu
quelques coups de matraque souhaitaient
les policiers mis en cause font partie
de ces brigades motorisées de la
préfecture de police se plaint
voltigeurs motocyclistes étaient
intervenus la nuit dernière au quartier
latin à la suite d'incidents provoqués
par des manifestants après l'évacuation
de la sorbonne par les forces de l'ordre
la mission de cette unité composée de
volontaires et d'intervenir pour éviter
par surprise en impressionnant le plus
possible adversaire pour le déstabiliser
malik oussékine était-il au nombre de
manifestants rien ne permet pour
l'instant de l'affirmer mais il a été
pris dans la nasse et n'a pas pu s'en
sortir
un autre témoin raconte un groupe de crs
qui descendait la rue sur les
manifestants qui se sont tirés dans la
rue
la foule que les crs sont restés
quelques secondes et puis on continue à
les poursuivre et à ce moment là
quelques secondes après encore sait plus
trop serré sortir de cet immeuble avec
un mec qu'ils ont littéralement tabassés
de façon extrêmement violente
extrêmement violente au milieu au milieu
on est de tourner de tout le monde même
si les coûts n'y a pas officiellement la
cause du décès de malik oussékine un
jeune homme de 22 ans est quand même
heure ici dans des circonstances qui
devront être éclaircies